la politique c'est le terrain c'est le
partage c'est aller vers l'autre c'est
ce qu'on c'est ce que je fais 24
24 Badia à la radio maire de r
délégation handicapé ville inclusive et
je suis la seule délégation en France je
viens du domaine associatif mon parcours
professionnel j'ai fait formation du
juriste par ma différence un moment
j'étais obligé d'arrêter parce que
l'accessibilité m'a coupé l'herbe sur
les pieds après j'ai élevé mes trois
enfants tout en travaillant je suis élu
depuis 2020 plusieurs années que je
travaille à côté de président moderne de
la Marne Franck Noë j'étais à côté de
lui comme associative je représentais
l'handicap en 2020 Monsieur le Maire il
m'a fait appel pour que je rentre dans
sa nouvelle
municipalité depuis que jeis suis à
cette délégation il a fallu le temps
pour la faire exister depuis 3 ans j'ai
réussi on a le service on a la
délégation on a des personnes qui
travaillent avec la délégation handicap
j'ai accepté d'être sur la liste MoDem
c'est grâce Franck Noël je me trouve
dans le modem tout ce que je fais sur le
terrain j'ai trouvé ma politique à moi
ma politique c'est le terrain ma
politique c'est d'être proche de l'autre
c'est d'aller voir l'autre la politique
est la vraie c'est pas rester derrière
un
bureau